hey what's up welcome to another episode
of get close I am your co-host Geo and
I'm Bart and I'm so glad to be back
because we took a slight Hiatus not
because we wanted to but because we had
to yeah I think we're gone for like four
weeks which never happens because we
always try to upload at least once a
week yeah but it's been nuts and it's
been tough just finding the nuts and
tough nuts and tough to find the time to
get everything put together what's been
some nuts well if we were to go like
um backtrack from earliest to now to the
latest earliest after when like now like
right now so like so right now it's it's
uh 5 11 right May 11th okay we go May
11th to May 10th I mean 9th versus may
all the way back to March or April got
it you know what I'm talking about some
earliest to now all right you lost me
but go ahead does that make sense
English I'm using regular freaking
English maybe I can understand what the
[__] I'm saying yeah no you're just
boring just go say what you want to say
I think I'm I'm just appalled
by everything that you represent so just
go what do I represent uh crusty feet
[__] that [__] personality like just
don't want you to marry me then I I
think I was having a rough patch okay
yeah that's all I want you to divorce me
then well I'm just lazy
again again yeah I don't make the same
mistake twice if you marry someone twice
and you divorced them once are you still
married if you marry them twice and you
divorce them once of course because you
get divorced twice yeah so why are we
doing math problems then we'll just get
married three times then you'll be way
too lazy to ever divorce and we'll never
get divorced just move it on what the
[__] happened so for me personally in
the last couple of weeks if you guys
follow me on Instagram which you should
Marquan
um it's been nuts I've been
back and forth from Vegas La so I have
my usual stuff which is I go there to
shoot JK news every two weeks that's
normal and when I don't have any other
things popping up it's actually
um very very manageable because now our
JK days are only two days so I literally
either go there the morning of or the
night before so I don't really miss out
on family time and I'm back in pretty
much two days or even a day if I go in
the morning of and I come back the night
up so it's actually not even bad at all
but um this year we're really trying to
push Marvel Brigade as hard as we can so
Mario Brigade is actually like four
businesses in one we have digital
programs we have our apparel our
supplements and then we have a gym
so when people think like JK Barbara
Brigade and the YouTube it's not one
thing it's not one and four it's one and
five actually because
the content itself is like JK it's like
a production house with four other
entities or five entities total so it's
like me doing JK and then five other
businesses and because of that I'm I've
been going there quite a bit in the last
couple of weeks to shoot all kinds of
content for programs for supplements for
apparel for the gym I had a power
lifting me and then we had a whole Texas
tour we shot with Tim Kennedy
um Nikki Rodriguez David Lucas like we
shot with all kinds of people
so
um it felt like my last couple weeks of
my life has been in a crazy Whirlwind
like literally in my master bedroom
right now I have my luggage open because
I've just been living out of my luggage
and I was about to I thought I was back
for good but tomorrow we're going to San
Diego to hang out with some friends and
that's a good thing but it's still
another thing yeah it's positive chaos
yeah
so you say all that to say what your
life's been great so I'm just saying two
uh earliest to now has already been like
that but even before then with us we had
a the last time we uploaded was before
our little trip to Tahoe first for type
of spring break we had all of that that
we're dealing with
um just there's just been so many life
changes and updates that I don't think
it's been okay slow it down bro slow it
down so this is what we're gonna do okay
we're gonna take it back to when we last
episode yeah yeah you're stressing me
the [__] out like it's not that crazy
like yes it's crazy but it ain't that
crazy right so when we last left off on
our podcast we hadn't even discussed
spring break we weren't thinking about
spring break because we were [__]
catching up on all the other [__] that
happened I think we were thinking about
it we just didn't know what the idea of
it got it okay so
go back to real life
um taika spring break is right around
the corner
I started toying with the idea of taking
taika to California and then
um unfortunately for taika's school
schedule and his cousin's school
schedule they don't align I think
they're like two weeks behind the whole
Squad yeah because I mean that's the
best right yeah but it just it does it
wasn't aligning the spring breaks are
what like a week or two hours two weeks
two weeks off two weeks off
um so initially I was like okay [__] it
it is what it is
um but I do want taika to go to
Disneyland because I grew up with
Disneyland I'm a SoCal kid Disneyland is
in our backyard so it's what you do like
if you grew up in SoCal that's what you
do Disneyland is your world so I want
taika to grow up the same way I did so I
was like dude he hasn't been to
Disneyland since maybe one time after it
opened up after we lost it for two years
because of covet and all that so I'm
like Okay cool so I'll do like a weekend
where we spend it you know two days you
know one day for the main Park the other
day for uh California Adventure and and
then now he's into Harry Potter so I'm
like [__] yeah now I can go to Universal
and justify the price because back in my
day Universal was like 40 bucks like he
was going downhill like it was so
inexpectful place you went to if you
can't afford Disneyland yeah you go
Disneyland University yeah it got really
bad while they're on a budget the
Knott's Berry Farm okay yeah yeah but
now when I was looking to make
reservations and stuff which is another
thing I was like what the [__] the
prices are just as close to uh
Disneyland yeah so if you guys are
trying to go to Disneyland or Universal
Studios you have to make reservations
because of covet protocol right so it's
like you can't just go and show up
anymore it's like you have to pick the
day the time or whatever and then you
have to make sure I forgot about that
yeah I forgot about that so I'm just
casually planning the way I would
normally plan because in my brain it's
come on come one come all type of deal
with all of these amusement parks yeah
so it was about a month out and I'm like
well out of curiosity let me just see
what the prices are then that's when I'm
hit with the reservations because the
the after or the after the covid
protocol was you have to reserve your
slot
so I'm like it should be fine so I look
at the weekend that I want to book yeah
sold out and it's not and it's not sold
out for like or I can't get tickets for
another month or so so it's all sold out
for the whole month whole month is sold
out two months out I think was sold out
and I'm like [__] man what are we gonna
do what a bummer but I don't like to
accept no's yeah so I'm like all right
[__] it we'll just go to uh no means yes
you're one of those types of people a no
means just find another way yes I like
that yeah so when the no came about I
was like all right well [__] it then
let's go to Florida what the [__] no no
means yes to me too
so you have like a really innocent
mischievous smile like your eyes say
more than like anything else yeah so you
have that and then you have a big ass
bobble head right and then on top of the
bobble head you have [__] big ass
[__] headphones you look even more
ridiculous okay so then I saw that note
and I was like all right time to Pivot
yeah so I'm like dude let's go to
Florida and you're a down ass [__] so
you're like let's [__] go to Florida
yeah so then uh that was the plan we're
gonna anyway we're gonna kill two birds
so I was like uh oh I think you brought
it up you're like hey why don't we go
and hang out and see KOA KOA is
um so it's um
KOA is a YouTuber family vlogger too
family vlogger it's uh uh I think it's
KK because it's KOA Karen and then
they're kids I think it's
kkken beautiful
ten beautiful half white happy one on
the way yeah yeah so so this video is
done there's gonna have two more
beautiful kids they're the ones keeping
our population alive and I'm happy
because they're the coolest [__]
people we need more good people like
that so thank you yeah for keeping the
humanity alive yeah so we're gonna meet
up with them and then uh because again I
was a month out
everyone had already they had the same
[__] idea we did so when I was trying
to book flights and hotel it was so
stupid expensive I'm like that it wasn't
worth it yeah the [__] is going on I
think it's like uh you know how there's
Bridezillas
I think there's momzilla's during spring
break and I've seen them because as a
kid you would see like the moms that are
planning and everything and they're
dragging people around the hotel come on
let's go let's go and then they're the
ones that like they really want to make
sure there's family time because it's so
hard to get a big family together yeah
like whether it's like your cousins too
or whatever so everyone wants to go as a
group
so I think like now I know spring break
plans with kids
two months in advance we got a plan uh
to avoid minimum yeah yeah so that got
too expensive and too expensive to the
point that I'm like this isn't even
worth it I think it was gonna be like
three thousand dollars total yeah yeah
it was gonna be like 3 000 just to go to
Disney World yeah and it was only for
gonna be for like less than a week
because the flights in the hotels yeah
it was ridiculous and I'm like okay this
doesn't make any [__] sense yeah
so I don't like to not enrich taika's
life as do you so I think I was like
well why don't we just take a road trip
and um I was like what if we take a road
trip all the way to Canada and like we
were like oh that'd be cool like we get
to go see we want to do Canada I want to
do Colorado
yeah and why don't we do Colorado well I
think we started mapping it out because
because taika has seizures like he needs
to have his afternoon naps so I think
we're trying to uh map out like a
realistic not like white knuckling all
the way there but like stop and go and
enjoy it's time to go and enjoy it nice
and comfy
um I think the time that we had which
was might have been only been five days
is not enough to go to Colorado and come
back I think we needed like maybe seven
or eight days
um but if you white-knuckled it yeah you
can get there real soon but we have a
kid with seizures we gotta what yeah his
seizures now we've figured out um are
triggered by Sleep the number one factor
yeah so because of that we're like okay
that doesn't make sense then I was like
well let's do Canada and we were like
dude that's a sick idea yeah same thing
right like it was gonna take too long
and it just didn't make sense so Bart
you're like a really good
um you've done all of our road trips
like all of our RV trips and stuff
you've been really good at planning and
figuring it all out like you already
know what websites to visit and Winters
are going to be a waste of time and
which ones are the actual good ones so
you plan it and you did such a great job
oh thank you um what was it again so we
started here we went to Death Valley so
we so the the road trip is a Vegas to
Tahoe uh back down to California to
spend your mom's birthday road trip
remember we took her to go see flowers
oh right but we took the route of the
back alley route from Nevada or Las
Vegas to Death Valley and then from
Death Valley through the back Reno end
of Tahoe through Tahoe we stopped by
Sacramento bless you to stay what's up
to our homie Asylum Mike bless you thank
you and then stop by San Francisco real
quick
um just so we could pick up like some
cool souvenirs and sourdough bread and
then come straight down to LA to spend
the next day with your mom
um for her birthday yeah and it was such
a cool experience I don't know how much
we spent on this trip but it couldn't
there's no way we spent more than three
thousand dollars watch we did no it was
under a thousand
um but it was so rad because you have
the coolest truck like you have your dad
truck that has like the cloth seats that
like we have we wrecked the [__] out of
your truck on this trip yeah I think
we've done it in another trip but this
trip really we even went through Mammoth
completely forgot yes we did go to
Mammoth so um the setup was super cool
so of course we brought Mia so it was me
was tyke in the front with us yes yeah
mostly because you bought a little
booster so you sit between us from most
of the trucks and you can see over the
dashboard finally so he gets to get a
nice little view yeah he's not a baby
anymore he's in a booster chair now yeah
so Bart's truck has a bench seat bench
seat in the front yeah which is [__]
I can't I can't remember a time I've
seen a bench truck other than like 70s
and [__] I bought that truck yeah if you
guys go back to watch when I was
shopping for a new truck Vlog I was like
my eyes were set on the TRX because it's
a raptor killer you guys know me I
[__] love horsepower and I'm like
dude this thing is badass carbon fiber
Dash everything six seven hundred horses
I'm like oh this is nice this is like a
sports car and truck and one
then I go back and I'm like I don't know
it's kind of like too fancy for me to
actually do the [__] that I want to do
in it because I'm gonna be like I don't
want to scratch this I don't want to get
dirt on the leather we go to uh Chevy
dealership and they told me they had a
bench seat truck and I'm like oh that's
exactly what I want my 700 horses or
have my kid sit in the front seat with
me 700 horses it is baby kid in the
front seat with me all [__] yeah okay
yeah so uh we had tyke in the front it
was me Papa driving and then in the back
we had Mia who has a ton of space like
this the backspace is so good especially
for someone like me who's almost six
feet it is comfy as [__] like I hate it
in the back because it's just not tall
people friendly but this truck is so
spacious so
um during the day Mia would sit back
there or on the on the couch and stuff
and then to the left to the right of her
we had our cooler that had like just in
case we're driving and there's nowhere
to get like food then we had like um uh
you were dieting too all right yeah we
brought food to just make simple on the
go lunch like uh I had ham Hawaiian
rolls Mayo mustard and some fruit and
obviously taika's milk because he still
drinks milk at night uh and before his
nap and then you were cutting so you had
[__] ground beef in there you had a
whole big old thing of like 96 for
ground beef
and um so my experience with like road
trips is anything can happen like
obviously you plan to hit restaurants
during certain meals or whatever but
there's sometimes there's in between so
if you need to be in a rush so we packed
snacks we had chips we had drinks and
then we had food in the cooler so that
was like our own little setup it was
like it anything more we would have been
RV status yeah that's too much yeah we
were like perfect we had a little
sleeping area in the back yeah so I
brought a pillow a sheet because I knew
my Maya I knew Mia was going to be
sitting in the back and I just didn't
want taika to be
um full of fur it's just icky so I even
brought a portable [__]
um vacuum and a lint roller so that as
soon as tyke it was Tiger's nap time I
would clean the back up for him put the
sheet over so he has a clean space then
I would prop the pillow on the on the
cooler and then he had his blanket and
then Mia because the truck is so
spacious would just sleep on the floor
right next to him and it was so [__]
cool like he would sleep for two hours
yeah I was like dude this guy doesn't
take a nap for two hours not even at
home no no it's usually like an hour but
I think it's because the car was cool
and it was constant in constant motion
maybe I feel like it always at least for
me I feel like it it triggers like me
being back in the room or something like
when like I hear the humming and like I
feel like slight movement like it's
rocking me so I tend to sleep pretty
sadly always take uh I always knock out
during takeoffs too do you do that in
the plane no I think it has the same car
effect for me so as soon as it starts
taking off I go
yeah right away you're out yeah we're
still in the tarmat and you're out
it's not even take off you're like
already out it's just me yeah it's just
you they also do [__] with the oxygen
level so maybe that's what's causing you
yeah they suffocate us no but it's yeah
yeah it's less so it definitely makes
you drowsy yeah but Taiko is super comfy
had his own little bed in the back Mia
sleeping right next to him just like a
little good guard dog yeah and then we
would just drive yes we went to Death
Valley and then we got this smart idea
to start collecting so my mom collect
well I started this for her but her I
don't know I don't want to make that up
but she collects magnets I was like hey
why don't we get my mom a magnet of all
these places we're about to hit up and
then I think you saw the sticker or
something and then we were like oh let's
start
um Plastering our cooler which we travel
with now because it's a brand new cooler
we just bought because [__] Bart
loved spending money because yetis are
[__] sick so he had to get a [__]
Yeti it had to be I'm like we already
have a [__] one I've been wanting for
a long we have so many [__] coolers
but anyway so we got a new one and we're
like dude let's just plaster it with all
the stickers of the areas we visit
um so we that's that's where our first
tradition started yeah we get the
sticker so it was Death Valley from
Death Valley we went to I think it went
straight to Mammoth but I feel like we
stopped somewhere did we
no I didn't went straight to Mammoth
yeah because it was like super [__]
dry yeah we visited like some sand dunes
and then like yeah it was hot and then
it went straight to extreme weather in
Mammoth and that was the first time I
saw Mammoth and it was like [__] 20
feet of just [__] packed snow yeah
and then for Mammoth we went to Lake
Tahoe Lake Tahoe and that was gorgeous
because it was like the in-between like
it was and there's that beautiful Lake
yeah we got there right as the sun was
setting it was incredible so perfect we
have to go back we have to go back and
then from Lake Tahoe we went to
Sacramento
okay
oh I think you're remembering between
Death Valley and Mammoth it was that
weird [__] hotel yeah maybe that's a
stop you're thinking about
well I do remember the mammoth Hotel was
sick I was like this is a straight up
Resort even taika was still the mountain
even taika was like hey the other hotel
that one was gross this one's good like
he he understands quality but the other
one had the app the animals that we took
pictures with yeah tiger was kissing a
sheep yeah like [__] goat or whatever
it was so cute okay so then from
to Mammoth Tahoe Tahoe to Sacramento
Sacramento yeah yeah Sacramento to L.A
San Francisco by San Francisco right San
Francisco and then to LA and then we
even did a little like two three mile
hike to get that perfect picture of the
Golden Gate Bridge yep we did that it
was perfect I had never I've gone to San
Francisco many times and I've never I've
never had a picture from that because
everyone usually had like that tourist
bottom angle but then this one it was
like boom right behind us yep and then
we went we made it just in time for my
mom's birthday and she likes to Super
Bloom stuff so we took her to see some
really dope flowers we stayed with her
for like a day yeah and then we came
back yep and that was a spring break and
it's it was so enriching for me me too I
don't know I mean I guess taika loved it
too because he just got to roam free and
he ended up seeing his cousins toward
the tail end of it when we went back to
California he loves snow he got to see
snow everywhere he [__] loves snow
and then Mia was just running free and
like she was full of sand and dirt and
just a bunch of fun stuff and her her
Talons were filed down because she was
just running so much like this dog has a
wonderful life even taika I remember at
the Sand Dunes he kept wanting me to
push him so he could tumble all the way
down yeah it's so soft yeah it was so
cool and I think by this point like we
had already gone through like you know
your Dad's passing and are moving and
taika's health and there was just so
much stress and you know I felt like I
didn't really get to decompress from all
of that so
um I didn't realize how much I needed to
just be out like even though on this
trip I was working and hustling hard
because like
um we had some major changes within the
company structure that I needed to take
on a different position
um that I was still kind of learning
this position and working as like you
were driving but that's kind of the
beauty of being on a road trip is you're
stuck yeah and you have a mobile hotspot
so you're working yeah yeah and because
you're stuck in a car to get to your
next destination I was able to just work
for like a good couple of hours in there
and and I didn't feel guilty for falling
behind things still kept moving forward
but I got so rejuvenated by just being
in nature and just enjoying it and I
can't remember being on my phone very
much other than like when I needed to
work and then I would just leave my
phone and just either snap a bunch of
pictures or just be present and I
remember coming back from this trip and
it sounds hectic right but it was so
cute and I was like so charged up and so
refreshed and I'm like damn everyone
needs to get out more and it was like
all of this stuff is accessible to
everyone it's free you know all you're
paying for is your gas to get there or
your transportation
but it's all free yeah nature is awesome
yeah it was the best and just kind of
seeing all the different terrains and
climate changes and stuff was Super Rad
and I kind of like a hectic traveling
schedule like that hectic in the in the
sense that
um every day we're trying a new thing
not hectic and like trying to jump pack
things yeah like what was cool that I
liked that you planned it was like one
day is driving and then we get to our
next destination at night sleep and then
in the morning we explore the new
destination and then we spent a whole
day exploring and then the next day we
leave in the morning arrive to the new
location at night sleep and then explore
the whole day so I thought that was so
perfect because we only had one activity
planned per location and it was the best
I feel like I just talked this whole
thing you have nothing to say what do
you mean I've been talking the whole
time let's talk about you're crazy all
right fine
um so we get back from that and that was
also like a really cool test because not
once did we see taika like
um get a little bit wonky on us because
in school
a mild seizure yeah yeah yeah because
like not all seizures I created equal
you know like the ones that we're all
used to experiencing are the ones where
you're like convulsing and people fall
on the floor and like you know the the
old stereotype is like oh put a pencil
in their mouth because they don't like
swallow their tongue which is false
um seizures come in many forms and some
of which is just them freezing and not
and and you're just like hello are you
there and they're just gone they're just
staring off into space that or just them
kind of like falling a little bit and
just kind of stumbling and then mumbling
and then like they have a tiny seizure
and then they'll come back so he didn't
have any of that whereas in his other
school he would have things like that
happen like his teacher would be like
hey I think he had a mild episode like
he was riding his bike and I was calling
his name and then he it seemed like he
was gonna ride his bike down a hill
because he wasn't like responding
and then he like comes to right in the
nick of time but like these little
things
um and the truck and the travel schedule
can be hectic you know because we're
constantly on the go
um
and and yeah no like there was he was
perfectly normal the whole time and his
last seizure was back in November
so all of December he didn't have a
seizure then January he didn't have a
seizure in all of February none marched
none April 9 now we're in Maine he's yet
to have a seizure and we're about to hit
that six-month Mark I know fingers
crossed so his health has been so good
that we started so he was taking two
medications one called vimpat and one
called Keppra yep
um we he was on the highest dosage of
Keppra and the seizures were still
coming still coming so because they were
still coming he's on the highest dosage
that just tells us and the doctor that
this Keppra thing is not working so
that's the same time uh Capra
was we thought was a contributor to some
of his behavioral issues that got him
kicked out of school yeah because Keppra
is one of those things that lowers your
inhibition so if you already have
impulse control it's even worse yeah and
um at his last school we were literally
getting calls like everything every week
every other week come pick him up but
he's the disturbance he did this he
threw a ball at some kid and it was just
like crazy
so like his seizures
um and his medication not only affected
him academically but it also affects us
and he had mood swings if we need to
work and he had mood swings and he would
be hard for him and then you know like
when you start when a kid starts getting
in trouble all the time he's getting
sent to principal's office and getting
phone calls and he's the only one
getting picked up he's missing out on
like school picture day school plays
like all the stuff that all his friends
are doing he's missing out on not only
that he's knows that he's the only one
getting in trouble so he's getting
really down on himself and there's times
where he's like I don't think I'm meant
to be a good kid and that would like
break my heart yeah he like it was so
lethargic
um he would get so lethargic and down on
himself when it was like we have to go
back to school because he was like damn
I'm about to hear it again yeah so uh we
finally found a new neurologist who was
like okay if Keppra is causing so many
other like unwanted side effects and
just disturbing the other parts of his
life let's see if we can introduce a new
medication that has less side effects
which is vimpat which is why he's on
both of them so the goal was to get him
on vinpat and then have both of them and
then eventually hopefully wean him off
Keppra but the caveat or not the caveat
but the contingency to that is he has to
have
let's be seizure free for six months
which is now yeah so I was getting to
that yeah
um so yeah when we introduced vimpat we
had a meeting with his doctor and we
were like Hey listen uh I was just
telling her like you know what
Keppra didn't work
obviously because he's on the highest
dosage
there's a month where he had no seizure
because we were messing around with his
sugar levels
um and his sleep then we introduced them
Pat I'm like is there any way we can
start weaning him off Keppra because we
know it doesn't work so at that point we
slowly started weaning him off of it
yesterday as a matter of fact was the
last Keppra he had to take
so it was like this really cool
celebration that we had at home we ended
up facing my mom and my brother and my
sister-in-law and all the kids and
everyone was big old Donuts got him a
big old Donut to celebrate you know the
effort that taika put into it
because uh he's so freaking smart that
I'm like dude you got to take a nap and
he'll be like well why Mom I don't want
to take a nap I'm not even tired which
we know he's tired
um but I'm like dude this is you know
every time you take a nap it it helps
you excuse me it helps you not get
seizures so as soon as I started
explaining it to him he was like okay I
got it Mom so he would take a nap so I
was telling him like dude because you're
listening and you're taking naps like
it's preventing you or it's helping you
not get seizures so like good job and
because of that I'm like look we're
reducing your your medicine and he would
see it every week he'd be like oh it's
getting lower it's getting lower it's
getting lower and yesterday he finally
got to see that this was the last one so
like you mentioned the doctor was like
Hey if we can keep him seizure free for
another six months which would make it a
perfect one year then he'll be off of
medication completely
and we think we found it we think it's
the sleeping yeah which is why we're
we've been so adamant like every day
sleeps between 8 and 8 30 weekends he
always has a nap and it's so much to the
point where like I I'm a big advocate of
like daily habits because I believe the
daily habits determine what your future
is so I try to get into Jiu Jitsu all
the time but if on the way to jiu jitsu
if he knocks out that seizures priority
number one so we just sit in the car
with them and we make sure to keep the
car moving so he can continue to sleep
because that's his body tell him he
needs to sleep and we just miss Jiu
Jitsu for the day but that's what we've
been yeah that's so interesting right
that like the I I wonder how much energy
he's actually using up that his body's
like [__]
stop like you're going a million miles
per hour like what the [__] I actually
think that's uh one of my own theories
for myself why I knock out so fast
because I have ADHD I was diagnosed with
that as a kid and my brain is thinking
about everything all the time that's so
interesting [__] fast because it
feels like you're not thinking about
[__] always that's how crazy it is and
then so by the time I like lay in bed I
think it's so easy for me to knock out
because I'm so exhausted
because of because I'm like out thinking
you like running circles around you like
with my eyes closed and my shoelace is
tied together yeah I mean as you're
thinking about [__] I'm actually getting
it done you know and that's how your
life's all [__] up and that's why when
I came in I cleaned it all up for you to
clean up your life buddy you're what for
starters when I first went over to go
visit you as like when we were dating
yeah you [__] said you're you're like
my sheets smell good huh you were so
proud of it I washed my sheets every
week oh you know what it smelled like it
smelled like you washed it just in water
because it just smelled like skin no way
you know that skin smell that like
sticks to fabric that's what all your
sheets that's what the inside of your
nose smells like oh that's interesting
because right now it doesn't smell like
that at all and you're constantly
complimenting how nice it smells yeah
because you're Mexican what does that
mean I don't use [__] fabuloso
everyone knows Mexicans are laundry
experts no we're just experts at
everything you literally take half of
the drying sheets and throw it in with
every load
s
try
so then what are
you what are you trying to like I
thought you were trying to fight me why
are you complimenting me you're so weird
I literally just said I run circles
around no you don't literally what I
just said you thought I'm fighting you
you thought I have your back where am I
I don't know I could be behind you right
now I know you don't know am I even in
front of you well the interesting thing
is when I ask you I'm like hey what are
you thinking about because I'm always so
curious you're like nothing because
words can't even describe words can't
even catch up to how fast my brain's
working
do you understand yeah that's literally
everyone's [__] brain that's how we
see [__] pictures that's how you
don't think in words because their brain
has so much energy they can't sleep
my brain is people with ADHD is like
constantly and then so I'm [__] so
tired by the time I get home
yeah either that I'm dealing with your
[__]
probably both
but yeah it's so interesting to me where
hit that his brain's just like
[__] stop so I I can tell he has
ADHD because he's also been diagnosed
and I can see he's like so I think
that's why he gets [__] exhausted too
give me the goddamn chills cause I'm
like God I [__] do that [__] yeah
because we've done all the mental
[__] brain scan tests yeah and every
single time they're like it is normal we
are due for one more eug scan I don't
think it's 24 hour I think it's the one
hour one
um just to kind of see how his brain is
reacting to the absence of this Keppra
drug I would say though no matter what
we did this year or whatever happens the
rest of the year I think our biggest
accomplishment as a team is getting
taika to get off Keppra and be seizure
free for six months [__] yeah that and
then helping him re-fucking assimilate
or just assimilate to this new program
when he was so down on himself like when
he moved from his old private school
which I [__] hate now to this new
public school
um his teacher was like Hey I'm not too
sure how they did stuff you know in that
old school but like right now his
writing is really bad like I can't tell
what is going on like
um like his math he's a little bit
behind like he was behind on so many
things and we were like oh really okay
so like a team we were like okay this is
his schedule remember like I came up
with a [__] schedule I'm like he
wakes up has breakfast then review re
this is when your mom was still living
with us yeah yeah yeah because then it
was that I think it was like a week or
two maybe even a month I think it was a
month my mom lived with us uh so after
my dad passed a month my mom lived with
us for a month because she just needed
to change up the energy because what she
experienced was too crazy yeah and then
in that month he had just got kicked out
of school but then it's two weeks out of
school because of the winter break so in
this whole month he had nothing to do
and I'm like I'm not gonna let my
[__] child [__] brought indoors
and [__] so yeah I remember writing a a
a a schedule out for takat to even read
too
so instead of putting words I did the
words obviously for your mom and the
time
um that I drew pictures like from this
hour to this hour he's doing reading and
then math and whatever
um that's cool yeah and then we did that
together then once he started this new
school then and his teacher told us he
is a little bit behind we're like uh
our son is not behind he's a bright
[__] boy so he would wake up in the
morning have his breakfast and then we
would do review time so it'd be like 10
minutes to 20 minutes of just like him
practicing his alphabet with the
appropriate stroke pattern and then it
would be he would do some math
and then he would do some sight words
and then he would have like 20 minutes
of free time or 30 minutes or whatever
and then at school I would make sure I
would drop him off at least 15 minutes
before the bell rang so he can get his
little Wiggles out and just kind of run
yeah so like we'd set that up for I
think these five months yeah and we've
been consistent with it we haven't
backed down and I think we just or not I
think but we just got his test results
today uh where they do this map testing
where they see where your kid is at in
comparison to his peers and then within
the state right yeah and then Taiko was
what I think he's like 80 he's above 80
percentile for Math and I think above
70. which is good so that means like um
out of all the out of like the way they
explained out of a out of a hundred kids
um he outperformed like 80 of them for
Math and then outperform like 70 of them
for the reading and writing part of it I
know I'm so proud of him and this school
is so great
um the whole faculty is awesome the
principal to the counselor to his
teacher
so the psychologist like everyone you
can feel is really really invested in
him and that's such a breath of fresh
air because at his old private school
which we pay like top dollar for and
also just close to three grand I'm gonna
say it because that [__] was not worth
it three grand a month and then even uh
the type of like
um faculty I experienced as a kid given
that I was probably a menace
um it always felt like I was a nuisance
or even Taiko was a nuisance and just
like trying to like how do we get rid of
this nuisance because it makes my job
hard over here it almost feels like okay
we know we got to get taika here how
what's the best way to get him here yeah
and it always feels like that and
they're trying not to isolate him from
his peers because they understand the
social aspect of it where they're like
yeah he comes to school to learn
but there's also the socializing aspect
and and living amongst this community of
people that you eventually have to do in
the real world yeah like I love that
they take that approach too yeah it was
hard man
um but no I love this school I love his
teacher because she's so Stern yet she's
very approachable and and and like taika
loves her and she's constantly telling
me like hey I'm just scared that you
know he's gonna feel like we're picking
on him a lot and I'm like trust me you
guys are a gem compared to his previous
school because he would never want to
hug his teachers and he had multiple
teachers yeah and he didn't want to hug
any of them and then with this one he
like loves her
um and and she'd be like well I don't
want him to get down on himself and I'm
like he is nowhere near that like he
doesn't even know anything is going on
um so I'm just I'm so proud of him he's
done all the work and you know we just
got a report today where he they were
telling us like
um since he has impulse control I think
it's because he's the youngest in his
class usually his peers are six going on
seven and
um he was he like he had just turned
five
and then as they're going seven to eight
or six going on seven or seven point
five he's barely going to turn six so
um they're thinking a lot of it has to
do with the maturity
for him but he it was such a refreshing
thing to hear that his teachers be like
well no he's like really polite he's
very honest he takes accountability and
I'm like
we're doing a good job like they didn't
say anything bad about him other than
going like it's just his impulse like
you can tell he's remorseful and he
doesn't want to do it and he knows right
from wrong
but he just has to try it I've seen it
yeah I see it all the time where like
he's trying to give you eye contact he
goes I'm telling you I'm listening but
my hand just wants to see what this
[__] plushie feels like
well even he explained it the other day
yeah the teachers made everyone like a
little chicken cup toy thing yeah and
then the teacher said anyone that
touches it isn't going to be able to
keep it and the title was saying my body
kept telling me to go and touching my
heart but my I told myself I can't do it
but my heart wanted it wanted to go over
there just touch it yeah it was such a
battle yeah man I just wanted to touch
it so bad but I just was like no
no yeah we're telling them hey that's
good you know what that's called that's
called self-control you had a lot of
self-control that was awesome yeah and
then the next day he'll get frustrated
and [__] throw away his laptop yeah
but yeah like out of all the things that
we've experienced so far in this year I
would say
um I would say last year
[__] last year last year could suck my
dick but last year we also made a
million bucks which is pretty funny yeah
okay I take it back I take it back so
that's amazing so last year I would say
last year's one of last year's biggest
wins is making a million making a
million dollars in real estate Yep this
year is we bought how many properties
this year already so this year we now
own four homes three of them are paid
off boom shakalaka suck my dick yeah so
we've been able to leverage that into
four homes now so um we actually just
posted something
um on my Instagram about like what are
some of the topics you want to talk
about on our podcast finances real
estate is something that we want to talk
about so we'll probably dive into that
in the next episode
um but yeah so we end up getting four
pads three of them fully paid off so
those are cash flowing really nicely
um that's what we've been able to do in
just this year and also the main
important thing is getting taika off
camera
seizure free so far and then feeling
confident in school to the point where
when we go so do you want to do some
math he goes yes yeah he loves math he
loves math he [__] loves someone that
created homework and hit his school and
you can sell it down on himself he was
to like love you math and feeling how
confident he is and like every time like
a Theo comes around he's like he wants
to do math games what's 40 plus 40 plus
2 minus two yeah it's complicated
combination yeah and then uh and he
feels so happy to be able to go back and
forth with someone on it yeah it is CUNY
um no I think we're I think we're doing
a great job
we did a great job good job team
maybe on the next podcast we'll talk
about uh how if we've how we have been
as a couple
because that's gonna need a whole new
podcast that needs a whole new podcast
why you got you got some secret [__]
that you haven't told me no I mean I was
just trying to be enticing for the next
one but you just didn't catch on
I told you I'd run into circles around
you no you didn't catch on I [__]
threw the [__] alley-oop and you
didn't dunk it you just saw the ball go
up and then you were running [__]
circles in your own goddamn brain that
you weren't in the present moment to
[__] catch it and [__] dunk it
because you threw the alley-oop at
someone that was even then I already
went home I was an Uber yeah thanks for
being a team player that's what I'm
talking about I said I'd run circles
around you can you please can you just
not run circles with your [__] ADHD
in the presence I'm a cinnamon roll baby
I go like this
more like a piece of [__] that goes like
this with frosting on it yeah I don't
know you're so lame but no we did a
really good job like uh we turned the
ship around we really and you know that
that little spring break road trip that
we did I think that was something that
we we really really needed because uh as
a family like we went through so much
with him getting kicked out of school
him not being in school for a whole
month I know and then remember like even
during that whole period we're taking
him to go check out schools remember we
would go see this school go see that
school go see that daycare go see
whatever oh right and then you can tell
like like taika can feel this isn't
normal like I said where am I going and
we had just moved into this place so he
feels absolutely displaced yeah yeah so
like Tito's like why am I seeing so many
schools and why am I seeing like if
teachers like me or if I like them and
then you can see that there's already a
full-blown class happening and he's like
the new one and then we're trying to
like because you know kids could feel it
you know and then so we're like do you
like this playground or do you like that
teacher and you could just feel like why
are my parents keep asking me these
things like wait why can't I go to the
other school and we can't really just
break it when we got kicked out because
you want them like to hurt his feelings
so we just have to kind of like soft
talk now he knows now he knows we have
to sugarcoat all these things and
um it was such a point in his life where
I feel like his like his shell was
closing in on him you know and then I
think for him to go to this school
develop some confidence and then for us
you know road trips are spending all day
together and he's sleeping in the bed
with you every single night so it feels
so super oh right super CUNY I think
like it was like a much needed thing for
us to like just be together and bond and
be together 24 7. yeah that was really
great that was really cute I ain't
trying to cry
but we did it man like we [__]
everyone has their [__] you know but you
just gotta keep continuing to focus on
that silver lining and like hopefully
having like people in your life that are
constantly
recognizing that there's an obstacle but
going hey that's not going to defeat us
and going okay what was the plan of
attack and let's just keep moving
forward because I think once you start
focusing on the obstacle then you're not
looking at anything past it and you're
just stuck yeah um and I'm so proud of
us to be like okay that's fine this fine
this is gonna be hard but here we go
let's [__] attack it and we did it
we did it and seamlessly we did it I
mean it's uh now it's such a part of our
routine that it feels weird not to do it
which is Super Rad because now we have a
really cool
um little shining little monkey man yeah
who's like kicking ass and loving school
and he's about to end school like in
the weeks not even a week tomorrow's
Friday Monday's his last day no no no no
no no no no I messed up no you're right
about six days
suck my dick Barton anyway on that note
I'm so proud of us
um
yeah we're doing great
and I have nothing else to say
well I'll end it if you guys like this
podcast please support us we go to
borrow brigade.com supplements apparel
uh digital programs stop by the gym
anything that is me and mod Bear's
business our own personal brand and uh
because we have that business that
allows us to keep doing this so make
sure you go check that out barbara.com
see you guys next time bye